what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting
to um nipsey hustle racks in the middle
as you guys
know i don't i watch mostly country
music i don't listen to a lot of rap
so all of these are like blind reactions
for
me okay let me show you just you know
somebody sent this to me on instagram so
if you guys have anything that you want
to submit send it to me on
instagram
[Music]
[Music]
a b12 okay a lot of times when they say
like
numbers and random letters i think it's
like a gun
so i'm guessing a b12 is like a type of
gun with like the racks
in the middle that's like money racks is
money
i was riding round in the v12 with the
racks in the middle
had afraid almighty god they let my dog
out the kennel when you get it straight
about the mud you can't imagine this
[ __ ]
[Music]
i got killers to the left of me we're
just lurking on them
they show no mercy on her we're just
going back-to-back we put a curfew on
her
it was dark clouds on us but that was
perfect for us we know you always crash
and burn but it was working for us let
me tip the v12 double check the details
gotta cross my teeth and dye my eyes or
i can't sleep well
millions off for retail okay so this is
good he's saying i gotta cross my t's
dot my eyes so i can't sleep well so
what he's basically saying
is that he likes to pay attention to
detail which i think is a really
important trait so so far this song has
a great message once again i prevail
knew that [ __ ] was over from the day i
dropped my pre-sale
hold up let the beat bill see me in the
street still
i've been fighting battles up a steep
hill they gave my road dog 12. it was a
sweet deal
and i've been riding solo trying to
rebuild
i was riding around in the v12 with the
rags in the middle
okay so now i'm thinking that the v12 or
the b12 might be a car if he's riding it
i thought it was a gun to start
but now i'm thinking it's a car my dog
when you get it straight about the mud
you can't imagine this [ __ ]
i been pulling up in the drop tops with
the baddest [ __ ]
okay so he's saying that he's pulling up
two parties with some attractive women
so
for men when you get a hot girl on your
arm
you look cooler so he's letting you know
that he can get the hottest females
[Music]
i got killers to the left of me under no
condition
would you ever catch me slipping
motivated shooters plus the maybach
chauffeur driven
they catch me with it don't send me off
to prison judge ain't sympathizing
court don't show forgiveness engine in
the lambo journaling out the music
simply or with the flowers five gold
cubers
champagne while i shop hope i splurge
foolish close an escrow twice this month
both commercial units
damn i wish my [ __ ] fast who's here how
you dying 30 something after banging all
them
okay so he's saying that he's really
super this is kind of sad so he's at
a graveyard he's really sad that his
friend died
so he's saying like you were bang us
back in all those years so i think he
was like
doing some stuff for a long time maybe
some entrepreneurial
activities and then he passed away so he
said you did all this and then you died
grammy nominated in the sign of shedding
tears all
[Music]
okay that's a good message too so he's
saying that no matter how much money you
have
you can't like get back time with
someone that passed away so to really
enjoy the time you have so that's a good
though
we just embraced the only life we know
if it was me i tell you [ __ ] let your
life and grow
until you finish where we started reach
the heights you know gas the v12 to the
pipe and smoke
i was riding around in the v12 with the
rags in the middle
how to pray to almighty god they let my
dog got the kennel when you get it
straight about the mud you can't imagine
this [ __ ]
so he said i had to pray to god to let
my dog out the kennel so i think when he
means dog he means like a homie
and anybody says kennel he means jail so
i prayed to god
that i keep my friend to get out of jail
i've been pulling up in the drop tops
with the baddest [ __ ]
[ __ ] been focused on my check got a new
cook wrap around my neck
[Music]
i got killers to the left of me another
million dollar bill that's just some
regular [ __ ]
see my granny on the jet some [ __ ] i'll
never forget
next day we flew to vegas with my puma
connects
[Music]
so he's saying that there was a game but
he knew it was chess so he's saying like
he thinks moves ahead which is smart he
also mentioned
that he was happy that his grandma got
to experience a jet he never thought
she'd be able to experience that
this song is some really good
[Music]
a couple things message can expect just
like money no money
[ __ ] shooters respect other shooters we
were both doing my crew on your neck
i'm on the freeway in the drop it got me
losing my breath i'm doing a dash with
the blues on the deck
oh she looks happy
[Music]
wow
[Music]
okay i thought that song had some pretty
good messages
i thought that they looked really cool
like on the jet
and stuff so i'm gonna give that song a
four out of five
i like to do one to five skills i think
they're more accurate forces people to
pick so i'm gonna say slightly above
average
four out of five let me know in the
comments if you agree or you disagree
with my analysis
do not forget to subscribe to the
channel as you guys know i'm trying to
hit 20 000 subscribers
so each and every one of you helps me
get to that goal and bring the
notification bell while you're at it
i'll talk to you guys
next time